This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more visit our website
Hello, this is six minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Sam and I'm Neil
It's nice to see you Neil smiley face high five fist bump. What is this Sam? Are you saying hello with emojis?
Yes, I am in this program. We're entering the world of emojis the small characters people use to show emotions in texts and emails
Do you have a favorite emoji Neil?
Mines that crying tears of laughter emoji. I like the smiling face with hearts one and with over three thousand emojis to choose from
There's one for every occasion
It's one of the reasons why emojis have become so popular over the last 20 years
They let people put back some of the human emotion that's missing in written texts and emails
We'll be finding out more about emojis and learning some related vocabulary soon
But first I have a question for you Neil
It's about the word emoji itself which was invented in 1999 in Japan for the first internet enabled mobile phones
The name emoji comes from the combination of two Japanese words
But which words is the word emoji a combination of a face and emotion be picture and character or see message and image
I'll say it's a face and emotion. Okay, Neil
We'll find out if your answer gets a thumbs up at the end of the program
When we talk with someone face to face we use physical gestures like smiling, laughing or nodding to show the other person how we feel
But these gestures get lost in written communication. That's where emojis come in
They add feeling and emotion to online messages, but not everyone is an emoji fan
Some people believe that carefully chosen words are the best way of expressing yourself and that emojis are affecting our ability to put feelings into words
Here's cognitive linguist professor Viv Evans author of a book about the language of emojis
Explaining more to BBC radio force word of mouth
A lot of people you know language mavens the grammar police and so on
Will say have the sort of jaundiced prejudice view about emoji that's taking us back to the dark ages of a literacy
Bring back Shakespeare and stick to the language of Shakespeare and all the rest of it
But that fundamentally misunderstands the nature of communication
Emoji is important in fact it makes us more effective communicators in the digital age
Viv Evans describes people who don't approve of emojis as the grammar police a
slang term referring to people who want to see formal language and grammar what they call correct English
Written online the grammar police criticize modern stars of English and like to correct other people's mistakes in spelling and grammar
According to professor Evans the grammar police have a jaundiced view of emojis
They only see the negative side of them because of their own ideas and experiences
What's more they think emojis are taking us back to the dark ages of illiteracy when most people couldn't read or write
If someone refers to the dark ages they mean a past time in history considered
Uncivilized and characterized by ignorance but luckily for emoji fans the grammar police are in the minority
Over six billion emoji messages are sent around the world every day with about
70% containing emotion-based characters like smiley face and blowing kisses
According to professor Evans emoji users are more expressive more effective communicators
So could that be an advantage for someone looking for love online?
That's what Michael Rosen presenter of BBC Radio 4's word of mouth wanted to find out
Is it possible to start a relationship using emoji?
Well, there is the research that's been conducted by match.com the American based
Dating site and what they found based on their research is that the people that use more emojis
tend to be luckier in love they have more success in terms of dating in the digital age
Using emoji makes us more effective communicators
expressive in more expressive
We're better able to express our emotional selves and people therefore it stands to reason if you use more emojis
You're gonna get more dates
For people who are dating or starting a romantic relationship with someone
It seems that using emojis helps them be lucky in love an expression meaning lucky in finding a romantic partner
emojis let us show our true personality
So professor Evans says it stands to reason in other words
It seems likely to be true that emoji users get more dates and that's a big thumbs up from me
What about our question Sam did my answer get a thumbs up to in my question?
I asked you which words combine to make up the Japanese word emoji and I guessed it was a face and emotion
Which was sad face the wrong answer I'm afraid in fact
emoji combines the words for picture and character in Japanese
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned about emojis starting with the grammar police
People who want correct spelling and grammar online and criticize those who don't if you have a
jaundiced view of something you only see the negative side because of your own bad experience with it the dark ages
describes a period in history characterized by ignorance and a lack of progress if you are dating someone you are spending time with them
romantically which means you are lucky in love an expression meaning lucky in finding a romantic partner and
Finally the phrase it stands to reason means that something seems likely to be true or it makes sense
Once again our six minutes are up by for now. Bye
six minutes from the BBC